[Musique]
résultat de vos votes du duel de
vendredi sur les bavures médicales si
vous êtes victime d'une bavure médicale
considérez-vous cette erreur comme une
fatalité 20 % une faute du médecin 73 %
sans opinion 6 % engageriez-vous alors
un procès contre le médecin oui sûrement
51 % oui peut-être 29 % non 19 %. lequel
des deux débatteurs vous a semblé le
plus convainquant Louis René président
de l'Ordre des médecins 19 % Fédia Julia
association des victimes des bavures
médicales 65 % ni l'un ni l'autre 15 %
très petit score nous n'avons reçu que
358 appel duel sur la 5 aujourd'hui un
duel exceptionnel puisque pour la
première fois ma connaissance je parle
sous votre contrôle messieurs dames
c'est la première fois que le Front
National est opposé à Lutte Ouvrière
Arlette laguillet membre de la Direction
Nationale de Lutte Ouvrière pour la 3oè
fois candidate aux élections
présidentiel et Jean-Claude Martinez
député du Front national dans l'héros
alors Arlette laguier vous connaissez le
principe de ce duel je n'interviens pas
sauf si vraiment ça chauffe trop fort et
nous écoutons vos arguments puisque le
thème de ce duel c'est quel avenir pour
la France à travers vos deux formations
politiques oui et bien d'abord je dirais
que le problème qui se pose aujourd'hui
au quand que je veux représenter
c'est-à-dire au camp des travailleurs
c'est le problème bien sûr
principalement du chômage de
l'abaissement du niveau de vie de
l'appauvrissement de la classe ouvrière
et face à cela le Front national n'a
qu'une démagogie n'a qu'une démagogie
anti-émigré à offrir aux électeurs je
m'appelle Martinez gu oui et je pèse mes
mots quand je dis démagogie parce que
vous vous en prenez aux travailleurs
immigrés parce que fondamentalement vous
êtes dans le camp de la bourgeoisie et
que lorsque vous attaquez les
travailleurs immigrés c'est toute la
classe ouvrière que vous attaquez or
cette classe ouvrière vous savez bien
vous vous devriez en tout cas le savoir
que pour en finir avec le chômage c'est
pas le problème de l'immigration que
c'est le problème de l'investissement
des capitaux que c'est le problème c'est
le problème que les capitaux qui
aujourd'hui se baladent de bourse en
bourse à la vitesse de la lumière sans
créer aucun bien utile sans créer aucune
nouvelle usine sans créer aucun nouvel
emploi et bien que ces capitaux
s'investissent dans la production c'est
ça la solution et toute votre démagogie
anti-immigré qui est une attaque contre
les travailleurs et bien ça n'a rien à
voir ce ne peut pas être une solution ce
n'en est pas une et c'est une solution
pour la bourgeoisie parce que la
bourgeoisie a intérêt et vous-même vous
êtes dans ce camp-là à diviser les
travailleurs entre eux à essayer de les
diviser entre travailleurs immigrés et
travailleurs nés dans ce pays entre
travailleurs qui ont du travail et ceux
qui n'en ont pas voilà votre démagogie
monsieur Martinez vous permettez que je
vous réponde madame gu je sais bien que
ça va vous étonner ou peut-être ça va
vous faire ni froid ni chaud mais quoi
que vous en en pensiez moi j'ai beaucoup
de considération pour votre action
politique AR Laguiller mais non quoi que
vous en pensiez besoin de votre
considération monsieur Mar nous somm non
mais j'ai beaucoup de considération
parce qu'il y a une foi et parce qu'il y
a une sincérité et si j'ai beaucoup de
considération croyez-moi c'est pas du
tout par condescendance parce que c'est
un petit peu les mêmes qualités que les
nôtres vous n'êtes pas une professionnel
de la politique je ne suis pas un
professionnel de la politique et je vous
dis tout de suite ce n'est pas moi qui
devrait être là aujourd'hui vous êtes
candidat aux élections présidentielles
moi je ne suis que parlementaire
aujourd'hui devrait avoir monsieur la
joign à ma place ou
mon je suis sûr que vous êtes d'accord
avec votre patron monsieur le écoutez
moi je suis sûr que l'ensemble
l'ensemble des téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent et des gens modestes et des
gens travailleurs comme vous dites à
juste raison et des ouvriers moi je vais
vous en parler tout à l'heure ils
adoreraient voir François mitteron
accrocher par Guiller parce qu'il doit
être gêné de vous rencontrer de même
qu'ils adoreraient voir Monsieur le
Premier Ministre s'expliquer sur le code
de la nationalité sur le salaire
maternel avec le président Jean-Marie le
PEL alors moi je vous dis tout de suite
je ne partage pas du tout la
condescendance qui est appliqué à votre
égard et moi je trouve ça tout à fait
révoltant en démocratie il n'y a pas des
grands candidats non il n'y a pas de
grands candidat il n'y a pas de petit
candidat alors quand les expressions du
type comment vous allez affronter la
Laguiller mais c'est pas raisonnable de
rencontrer la chtroufette du trosquisme
non moi je trouve ça absolument
inadmissible et moi je vous propose
madame lag Guillet que nous ayons un
débat sérieux sincère parce que vous
êtes sincère et parce que je le suis sur
les thèmes que vous avez indiqué sur la
justice sociale dans notre pays sur la
justice à l'école sur la justice dans
l'entreprise sur la justice à
l'université sur la justice fiscale et
puis les téléspectateur verront bien où
la réalité je voudrais simplement avant
de vous repasser la parole à guuiller
vous dire la chose suivante vous savez
ce que c'est la justice aujourd'hui
est-ce que ça devrait c'est
effectivement d'en finir avec
l'enrichissement de la bourgeoisie qui
se fait au détriment de
l'appauvrissement de la plus grande
majorité de population une seconde juste
je vous demande n'oubliez pas le
proverbe de notre pays l'habit ne fait
pas le le moine et de même qu'il ne
suffit pas à Madame Fabius d'avoir une
de chevaux pour faire oublier qu'elle
est milliardaire ne croyez pas que parce
que j'arrive avec un costume croisé gris
que je ne sais pas ce qu'est le peuple
dans le camp des milliardaires il y a
aussi Monsieur le madame la Guiller j'en
vienstitimerie Lambert mais non j'en
viens et je vous raconterai où j'ai
passé mon weekend et avec qui tout à
l'heure je vous redonne la parole madame
lag guuer parce qu'encore une fois c'est
vous qui êtes candidat au présidentiel
oui alors ce que j'ai à dire
effectivement c'est nous sommes vraiment
pas du même camp je vous
ai j'ai lu j'ai lu vos déclarations dans
le monde au meeting de Montpellier
c'est du passé vous êtes l'homme du
passé vos
référen c'est Jean dark c'est Charles
Martel c'est le passé nous nous sommes
l'avenir par nous som nous sommes pour
en finir effectivement avec les
inégalité avec les injustices mais pour
ça pour ça il faut s'en prendre au
privilège de la bourois non vous n'êtes
pas d'accord avec ça et quand votre
patron Monsieur Le Pen parle de BMC
cette expression triviale et bien moi je
dis on peut
mettreanirac et on peut mettre le Pen
vous êtes de la même maison du camp des
bourgeois contre le camp des si on
parler de choses concrètes allez pour
les présidentielles oui alors vous
voulez que j'en parle pour donner un
petit peuancer allez-y bon très bien
écoutez madame la Guiller il y a des
choses qui ne peuvent pas aller que la
famille n'existe en Éthiopie c'est déjà
révoltant mais qu'il y ait des gens qui
au moins de 50 francs par jour pour
vivre c'est absolument scandaleux dans
un pays qui est membre permanent du
Conseil de sécurité qui est la troisè
puissance maritime du monde c'est
inadmissible que les mares de famille
que le total des maères de famille
rendent un travail qui est égal à 48
milliards d'heur de travail alors que
l'ensemble des actifs dans notre pays ne
représente que 41 milliards les maères
de famille font 7 milliards de plus
d'heur de travail elles n'ont pas de
rémunération c'est scandaleux que des
chômeurs en fin de droit sot absolument
la misère c'est absolument inadmissible
quoi que vous en pensiez vous attaquer
au capitaux parce que je vais vous dire
dans le mois qui suiv qui suivra notre
accession pouvoir ce problème de la
misère moi je m'en fais fort ce problème
de la misère madame la Guillet ça
devrait être le problème prioritaire
parce ça ne peut pas attendre le grand
marché de 92 monsieur ch lui peut
attendre monsieur bar peut attendre mais
celui qui a moins de 50 francs moins de
30 francs par jour il peut pas attendre
et quoi que vous en
pensiez frontières au travailleurs vous
êes pas pour la fermeture des frres les
CAP vais vous en parler pas du tout gne
pas de Benetti goldmi ouin qui ont même
pas la
National oui mais ça vous gêne pas que
leurs capitaux qu'ils ont réalisé ici
sur la soire des ouvriers qui soient
français et immigrés il les réenvoie à
l'étranger ça ça vous gêne pas là vous
êtes pas nationaliste pour l'argent vous
n'êtes pas nationaliste vousêtes
nationaliste que pour les travaurs c'est
pas du tout ça écoutez madame lag
abordons ce problème de la façon la plus
simple est-ce que vous croyez qu'il est
normal que dans les gens qui sont au
chômage qui sont la misère dans les gens
qui sont à la misère près de 40 % sont à
la misère à cause du chômage près de 33
% sont à la misère à cause de la maladie
et même plus terrible moi un chiffre qui
me révolte et qui doit vous révolter 8 %
des personnes qui sonentent à la misère
sonent à la misère à cause d'une
maternité c'estàdire un facteur de joie
un facteur de chance un facteur d'avenir
comme vous disait de la Guiller devient
un facteur de misère ça ça ne peut pas
alleroui maternel pour la pour qué de
raisons nous allons parler croz-mo parce
que le budget de l'État
il est bien plus consacré à l'armement
parce que ah ça l'armement leure à F oui
là on est prêt à débloquer je sais plus
milliards pour les ma de famille pas de
ressources là on prend pas sur le budget
de l'étatous scandalis sur les
de sur le Budet de l'armement nous pour
en finir avec laavons pas besoin de
prendre sur le budget l'armement moi je
vais vous dire nous allons prendre
l'argent madame la Guill nous allons
simplement relancer les entreprises nous
allons simplement relancer l'économie et
nous allons le faire la réponse elle est
très simple si les entreprises ne
fonctionnent pas s'il y a de chômeurs
c'est que nous avons enfin nous avons
ils ont étouffé les entreprises par les
charges sociales par les charges
fiscales nous avons eu déjà le débat
iimpô sur les sociétés n'arrêent pas de
diminuer et tous les
candidats soit
soouou vous êtes pour la diminution de
l'impôt sur les entreprises je ne suis
pas pour la diminution de l'impôt sur
les sociétés parce que c'est une anorie
technique les sociétés n'existent pas il
n'existe que des cadres des sociétés les
entreprises n'existent pas il n'existe
que des entrepreneurs moi je n'ai jamais
fait un débat avec une entreprise ou une
société je ne suis jamais parti en
vacances avec une société ou une
entreprise éventuellement je rencontre
des cadres je rencontre des
entrepreneurs mais je ne sais pas ce
qu'est une entreprise je sais ce qu'est
un entrepreneur nous ce que nous voulons
c'est alléger la charge fiscale des
entrepreneurs est-ce que vous trouvez
normal madame m la Guill est-ce que vous
trouvez normal qu'un commerçant qu'un
artisan qu'un cadre qu'un taxiteur
travaille 70 he par semaine beaucoup
plus que au Crédit Lyonnais où on
travaille 35 ou 39 he et avec des
charges fiscales extrêmement lourdes le
jour on va enlever cette pression
fiscale sur les entreprises et cette
pression sociale harl de la Guiller
comme par miracle vous allez voir les
emplois secréage de tous les
représentants de la bourgeoisie qu'on
nous sert depuis 10 ans oui
d'accord
fairemrav rouge c'est déjà un signe
comme l'oriflam de SaintDenis oui mais
vous défendz vous défendez les intérêts
de la
bourgeoisieousfend les intérêts de
la depuis le début de la crise raconm
depuis le début de la crise depuis 15
ans oui il y a une crise mais bien sûr
qu' crise ilen à la l ilent on n' pas
arrêté de dire aux travailleurs il faut
diminuer les charges des entreprises les
et ils l'ont fait
faitit vous êtes vous vous êtes dans ce
camp-là dans le camp qui consiste à dire
aux travailleurs faites des sacrifices
pour que les entreprises
investissent 10 ans ça fait 10 ans que
les entreprises font des super bénéfices
qu'elles n'investissent pas qu'ell joue
sur toutes les bourses du monde ou
qu'elle perd dans de sombres
spéculations financières comme on l'a vu
avec la COG ris tout à fait scandalisé
comme vous m nous nous sommes pour la
justice à l'école à l'université la
justice fiscale la justiceut arrêter de
dire que il faut que les travailleurs se
sacrifient pour les entreprises parce
que depuis 10
ans
ai il faut que ça aille mieux pour les
entreprises je vous dis les bénéfices
des entreprises ils sont importants mais
ils sont pas réinvestis et ces bénéfices
ils sont faits sur l'appauvrissement de
la classe ouvrière vous savez bien ce
que c'est que le SMIC aujourd'hui les
patrouillir bien sûr vous le
savez suis pas le représentant du CNPF
madame la Guillet je vous faites
allusion à ce qui est paru dans la
presse il y a deux ou TR jours où le
CNPF veut annualiser le SMIC oui
diminuer le SMIC ça veut ça veut dire le
diminuer mais notre problème ce n'est
pas Madame lag
Guiller je crois que vous confondez
beaucoup de choses et encore une fois
même si vous ne me croyez pas moi je
suis en face sur votre constat et non
pas sur vos solutions notre problème ce
n'est pas de généraliser les restaurants
du cœur ce n'est pas de généraliser le
Secours catholique ou France solidarité
comme a fait Jean-Pierre cirebois pour
que les gens puissent s'habiller c'est
pas ça notre problème c'est pas comme il
le à 4007 ou à 4900 francs c'est
absolument scandaleux notre problème ARL
lag guuiller c'est que le pays devienne
riche et il a les possibilités de
devenir riche et les obstacles pour
qu'il deviennent qui empêcheent qu'il
deviennent riche ce sont la pression
fiscale c'est la pression des
cotisations sociales il faut enlever ces
chaussures de plomb
r comme BMC comme vous dites
comme vous êes dans le même camp arrêtez
de
TR
l'z saz combien éta perdu à la Bourse de
Paris le
M madame CR 5000 emplois pendant 5 ans à
6000 Fran par mois char comprise alors
qu'on arrête de nous dire qu'il faut
aider les entreprises c'est les
travailleurs qui faut aider aujourd'hui
les entreprises elles croulent sous le
fr elles ne produisent rien d'utille ne
me dites pas qu'il y a pas des Logel
choseoui oui oui le crédit Lionnais
grâce au travail de ces travailleurs oui
c'est vraiou parce qu'il travaillei vous
en disiez comme tous les
travailleursant des professeurs de fa de
droit mon
les vraeurs de produ c'est l'agriculture
c'est l'industrie et c'est pas leeur
terti et par exemple dans le cas de la
Communauté européenne moi j'étais encore
près de la frontière de Belgique à hson
il y a 3 jours les quotas laitiers c'est
scandaleux d'empêcher des gens de
produire du lait de produire la viande
des gens qui ont faim dans notre pays
c'est absolument choquant madame la
Guiller et moi je voudrais qu'on parle
vous et moi de l'école parce que l'école
ça peut être aussi un facteur de justice
colossale et je voudrais qu'on parle de
la justice sociale et de la justice à
l'université où on donne à peu près le
diplôme à tout le monde mais sorti de
l'université seuls les enfants de riches
peuvent faire quelque chose de leur
diplôme dévalués et les enfants
d'ouvriers les enfants d'employés ne
peuvent rien en faire moi aussi ça me
choque madame la Guillet encore une fois
quoi que vous en pensiez nous sommes
souvent d'accord sur le constat mais
nous divergeons sur les solutions parce
que vos solutions sont pas raisonnables
qu'est-ce que nous voulonsad les
solutions ne sont pas raisonn est-ce que
vous êtes prêt vous à réquisitionner les
capitaux spéculatifs pour les obliger à
s'investir dans la production à créer
des emplois parce que moi je prétends je
prétends qu'on manque de tout y compris
dans ce pays et qu'on
aurait va falloir que vous nous rejoz
madame voustiz vos 3% avec les ntres et
là nous ferons la grande révolution le
24 avril je vous répète nous sommes pas
dans le même camp je fais pas moi le
panque de l'OAS de ces posurs de Bom
savez madame il sont ét des gens déchiré
qui un moment donné on assuré l'armée on
assuré l'honneur de l'armée de notre
pays
madame les assassins madame les
assassins ce sont les preneurs d'otage
et on les laisse agir vous le savez
madame ce sont certains des confrères
de il y a que de mauvais assassins
madame la guuiller écoutez nous
qu'est-ce que nous voulons nous voulons
une grande école dans notre pays nous
voulons une grande économie nous voulons
une grande place pour notre pays dans le
monde qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire
pour ça alors tout à l'heure vous me
disiez vous allez prendre l'argent et
cetera je ne sais plus très bien à qui
les grands capitaux la réponse elle est
très simple si vous aviez écouté le
débat et je sais que candidat au
présidentielle vous avez beaucoup
d'autres choses à faire le débat que
nous avons eu ici même avec Monsieur
Pierret je lui dit nous nous exonérerons
en S C an de l'impôt sur revenu mais
pour les contribuables les plus élevés
les cadres supérieurs et voilà la
réponse à votre question ARL lag
guuillet nous les exonérerons sous
conditions de remploi en investissement
et ça évitera que ça parte à l'étranger
comme vous le redoutez vous voyez vous
avez un souci qui est légitime et nous
avons
rargent cadres l'argent des contribuabl
mais pas de créer les entreprises mais
de créer des investissements des de
l'immigration la même démagogie vousit
déame monsieur vous êtes sûrement très
fort en statisti moi je lis les feuilles
de
P SMIC aujourd'hui 4900 franc 4700ez
vous savez même pas ou déjà prêt à les
augmenter tout de suite n pas
admissit qui te fait nett moin 4000
franc pour impô ça veut dire qu'il paye
environ 500 francs d'impôts alors vous
voulez bien les exonérer de ça mais vous
continuerez à les faire payer 186%
moyenne de TVA c'est-à-dire 6500 francs
de TVA par an soit un mois et demi du
salaire
d' je vais vous montrer tout de suite
que vous êtes trompé mais avec beaucoup
d'affection parce que moi j'ai
l'affection affection je vous répète les
gens comme vous monsieur comme votre
patron Monsieur Le Pen qui disent que le
chambre à gage c'est un détail du passé
et ben j'ai bien peur j'ai bien peur que
demain ce soit votre détail pour
l'avenir et mon combat il est contre ça
moi ce que je vous propose madame la
Guill est tout de suite sur la TVA si
nous pouvons exonérer les petits
contribuables en France en dépit de
l'erreur qui est commise par tout le
monde y compris par le plus grand
économiste de Lyon c'est parce que
précisément il y a une t va élevé en
France à 33 un/3 que la France à la
différence de tous les autres pays du
monde occidental peut exonérer ses petit
contribuable grâce à la TVA moi je
voudrais vous dire la chose suivante la
Guill le 24 avril l'élection peut
basculer à 500 ou à 700000 voix ce sont
à peu près votre score d'ailleurs vous
avez fait votre meilleur score en 1981
dans la Creuse avec 2,99 % des voix à un
endroit où il y a pas un seul ouvrier
donc ne croyez pas que vous avez
l'électorat ouvrier votre meilleur score
vous l' FA l'lect ouvriadame votre
meilleur score vous l'avez fait dans la
Creuse dans la Creuse il y a pas un seul
ouvrier le problème n'est pas là
madame madame gu si c'est 3 % de votre
sincérité de votre pêche de votre foi
qui sont aussi les nôtres si c'est 3 %
rejoignent mais si vous avez de
voulofendreamp
TR attaqué par tout le monde compris par
Monsieur Leen pas du tout mais pas du
tout mais pas du tout il est antiouvrier
il est contre les fonctionnaires contre
les
syndicalre écoutez moi j'ai presque
envie de vous dire tellement j'ai
l'affction appelez-moi Jean-Claude je
vous
appel Mo
j'aicunreamp reozreamp nous fons la
grand Révolution le 24 avr vous allez
gasp
500 nous pouvons tout changer madame
d'ailleurs je vous ai amené un cadeau je
vous amené mon livre les PR jours- Mar
Le
Pen mais non madame lag guuer mais non
madame lag guuier et vous verrez que ce
n'est pas ce que vous pensez vous avez
parlé de non m'appelez pas arlelez-moi
Jean-Claude moi jeis vous raconter mon
weekend raconter mon weekend je l'
dépassé avec des des hommes de la CGT de
forces ouvrire avec des descendants de
Raoul cas avec des chômeurs de la Moby
j'ai passé mon weekend avec des chômeurs
la Moby à franan qui a fermé avec des
ouvriers l'usine d'ge avec desers de
Saintin vous savez ce m' raconé madame
je vous Racon les grèves de juillet 1929
lorsque les ouvriers se mettaient en
grève pour pouvoir protéger leurs pieds
avec des sacs pour ne pas que leurs
pieds soi rangés avec de l'acide et ben
moi je suis dans ce camp là je ne serai
jamais dans le camp du milliardaire
Fab ouvriers de chausson sont en gr dans
la région parisienne depuis 3 semaines
pour 1000 franc de plus par
mois et pour les mineurs des houillerses
de Lorine qui gagne de 3200 à 4000
francs vous êtes pour leur donner 1an
deation par
MO je vous donne la réponse tout de
suite de tout mon cœur du fin fond de
mon cœur je vous donne la réponse
suivante si nous arrivons au pouvoir et
le moment sociologique d'arriver au
pouvoir le moment sociologique pour les
travailleurs je l'espère le moment
sociologique d'arriver au pouvoir a
commencé madame la Guillet dans le mois
qui suivra moi je n'attendrai pas 1992
parce que je suis Madame gu quoi que
vous en pensiez encore une fois l'abille
ne fait pas le moine je suis issu comme
vous du fin fond du peuple dans le
MO dans le mois qui viendra madame la
Guiller moi je ne veux plus qu'il y ait
une seule personne dans notre pays qui
soit obligé de s'humilier aller manger
dans les restaant dans le mois c'est pas
1000 francs c'est une h 1000 francs bien
sûr on ne vit pas dans notre pays à 1000
francs vous savez très bien qu'on ne vit
pas au moins de 6000 ou de 7000
franc
ème n pas pays PV dans le mois viend je
veux plus qu' dans
pay des gens quiroid des gens qui sont
obligés d'aller au Secours catholique
pour avoir des
[Musique]
vvolution
madame s'il vous
plat monsieur Martinez merci c'était
j'ai cru comprendre qu'on n pas tout à
fait d'accord sur l'ensemble du débat
monsieur Martinez je peux vous poser une
question indiscrète vous êtes marié bien
sûr ah d'accord parce que j'ai vu que
vous faisiez sans arrêt des appels à
c'est dramatique la situation la
situation des des des maères de famille
qui travaillent 57 he par semaine une m
Deb le débat est terminé le débat est
terminé débat est terminé s'il vous
plaît con mieux le problème des femmes
qui' vous PL madame la Guillet monsieur
Martinez bien les téléspectateurs de la
5 dotés d'un Minitel peuvent donner leur
sentiments sur ce duel passionnel je
donnerai les premières tendances vers
13h30 oui j'avais cru le comprendre vers
13h30 et je donnerai les résultats
définitifs demain alors demain un duel
exceptionnel également ce sera le 100e
duel et ce sera Valérie g Valérie
Giscard desestin l'ancien président de
la République face à des lycéens qui
donc seront à vos places madame et
monsieurs merci d'avoir participé à ce
duel exceptionnel et dans quelques
secondes le journal de 13h de la 5 non
non c'est fini
merci